ciao a tutti benvenuti sul tasto ris
nel frattempo c'è qualcuno che volente e
un merlino anche marlin vuole entrare
nell'armadio questa cosa ci fai nascosta
nell'armadio sono nell'armadio perché mi
sto nascondendo ta alti perché questa è
una nuova challenge a grandissima
richiesta trovo agli ingredienti slime
nascosti da alti di notte con le pile
ho pensato se dobbiamo farlo oddio super
inquietanti subito la pira così lino che
c'è che certi cercato di avvisarmi per
qualcosa che forse palchi qua vicino
vabbè chiara vasco io rimango nascosto
nell'armadio comunque in pratica ho
pensato come facciamo a fare questa
challenge di notte non vedo niente
ovviamente quindi ho deciso di fare
questa challenge con la pila anche se
sarà un po pericoloso perché baldi e si
accorgerà prima della luce quindi non
potrà usarla a tutto il tempo ma
solamente quando è necessario come
funziona questa chance se non avete
visto in di episodi precedenti dove
trovare tutti ingredienti slime è
riuscire a fare lo slime prima che baldi
mi prenda se baldi mi prende
ho perso la challenge ma se io riesco a
fare lo slime baldi scompare
se avete visto l'episodio presidente
sapete che ho perso ma ho letto i vostri
commenti dei consigli su come risolvere
quella formula matematica e quindi forse
questa volta c'è la rende tipo cornee
lasciate un bel mi piace perché se
volete una terza parte
se questo video raggiunge il 45 mila mi
piace uscirà una terza parte e ora siete
pronti ci stiamo ad esplorare e andiamo
a vedere dove sono nascosti perrino ma
perché stai bloccando la porta ma
insomma
[Musica]
si è un po il ritmo forse vuole entrare
nell'armadio perché c'è qualche giochino
no no no non leccare la pira nella
spengo ok ragazzi siamo usciti dall
armadio fortunatamente questa stanza non
è troppo puglia
esploriamo e vediamo un post rujano già
qualche quadernino mi raccomando poi nei
commenti scrivetemi sempre essere
riusciti a vedere i quaderni nico
intorno vediamo quanto siete attenti
[Musica]
abbiamo già trovato un primo quadernino
questo super facile vediamo con la
formula ok questa volta c'è anche
scritto scusa riesco a prendere se
ritorno in queste formule
sembra facile ma non ho una band a fare
una penna berlino dove sono le penne
dove dove sono le pene berlino c'è una
matita con perché funzioni sicuramente
questi sbagli perchè voglio anche arrivi
allucinante su quello che non si arrabbi
sedi e la sto rubando c'è la sta solo
prendendo in prestito di chi ha sentito
il rumore è era già qua la ciotola ma se
avete visto l'episodio precedente sapete
che se io trovavo a prenderla senza aver
risolto le formule si buttava baldi e mi
prendeva qui si cela sotto le divas
finora sta andando su per bene questa
challenge ora proviamo ad esplorare
fuori da questa
la cosa perché sembra molto buio lee sun
java
[Musica]
[Applauso]
bravissimo sta cercando di avvisarmi
roberto 50 55 st pani cavill amy
[Musica]
bravo meno male mi hai seguito parali
baldi era nel corridoio come faccio a
trarne lottato per lui unico e controllo
proviamo fate mancare senza per così
quella così potrebbe non si accorge che
ci sono
[Musica]
va bene
marino non merlino seppellito gli ha
portato il suo gioco senza che bosico di
a giocare ma non vuole giocare con
berlino
[Musica]
balle
io
[Musica]
altrimenti troppo rumore
i nomi fiscale con un posto adesso
fighter for more invece spiace tornare
tutto un po quando abbiamo lanciato dai
giornalisti pallini barker ha subito per
con la vecchia sopra fasi io non ho
fatto niente
[Musica]
ok ora che berlino ha smesso di fare il
rumore e vado a prendere qui un
quadernino nostra realtà non giusto
prenderlo
[Musica]
no
io
grazie tante se mi faccio subito
scappo
di carlo carretto la pillola tipo aperta
c'è qualcosa sotto penso che mi ha
avviato la fila perché ha fatto qualcosa
scritto sopra magari riesce ad
individuare una nuova clutch in quindi
proverò ad andare senza birra non mi fai
vivaldi
[Musica]
scuola mi ero completamente dimenticato
ok baldi 0 che non lascia più finire
completamente dimenticata telerecord
della scuola non bisogna correre non
bisogna mangiare non bere quindi a fare
silenzio bisogna scappare dal vestito
per fortuna non mi ha mai messo in
castigo
con questa sera non guardate adesso
centro nella fantastica un rapporto a
prendere la vita perché l'attesa per
niente la bella
[Musica]
ok ma no mi sono dimenticata la penna
non posso portare questa pelle gigante
con risate non avrà prenderti alla pila
che le pene per chi è vista così
attaccato addosso o per perdere si stava
per prendere questa volta della così
vicina a prendere la colla
[Musica]
tra patto stesso
però facciamo tre più 25 per chiarire la
cosa con questi amori marino stato
[Musica]
così
e quasi uno scooter ma io non
casualmente il piccolo ma solamente li
ritraggono trascrizione
un tempo io non stavo cercando in quella
stanza invece l'acqua il bicarbonato
[Musica]
la soluzione per tutti ma non so non ho
idea di dove possa essere però
continuare a giocare in quei corridoi ma
sicuramente tanti anni
[Musica]
ho paura che risponde all improvviso
che cosa e così è successo prima pensavo
che porti mi avesse preso ma come
aspetto la luce la luce la pila forse
non riusciva più a vedermi è andato via
ho trovato un modo per riuscire a
scappare più facilmente allora ho sempre
spegnere la pila che penso che lui non
vedo molto bene al buio come me
d'altronde comunque dovremo trovare
l'ultimo ingrediente non posso perdere
adesso dopo tutti gli ingredienti che ho
trovato tra avviando lo centro sta
iniziando a sbattere le cose se troviamo
qualcosa qua
[Musica]
guardi
vediamolo a tergo
[Musica]
carino no no no no no bellissimo bambino
e da qualche altro che fa più 63 per 305
più 20 numero molto per contro più 15 34
ora idea di moto fatto parte poker linea
stare tutti i miei cosa parla togliendo
ragazzi avete visto quella formula è
impossibile per me riuscire a risolverlo
sì ho mai però mi è venuta un'idea devo
prendere il cellulare portarlo con me e
usare la calcolatrice
non so se significa barare nel gioco di
paesi penso di sì perché non si può
usare la calcolatrice quindi penso che
lui si arrabbierà perché sarò barando ma
è l'unico modo in cui riuscirò a
risolvere quella formula almeno quando
cellulare o anche la pila così non devo
portarmi con la pila enorme siete pronti
stavo dimenticando la mattina se me la
dimentico di nuovo poi devo tornare
indietro nuovamente ok
anzi lo aggancio qua ecco fatto ora
attivo la pila ecco fatto chi l'ha
attivata
siete pronti ce la possiamo fare porto
il tifo per me andiamo
[Musica]
ecco 48 più 63 x 3
nono tempo per vedere cosa sta facendo
berlino più 22 meno 8x4 devo stare
attenta a non sbagliare altrimenti sei
sbagliato a perdere la challenge più 15
per marino marino che stai facendo
berlino popolo tempo per comprare il
bambino
la risposta è tutto 35 mirko subito
[Musica]
spero che sia giusta altrimenti siamo
spacciati finita o non è successo niente
[Musica]
sbrighiamoci ingredienti subito subito
se dopo baldi arrabbiatissimo non so se
sia perché ho sbagliato la formula
matematica o se ho fatto qualcos'altro
di sbagliato non mi sembra di aver fatto
tutto giusto scrivetemi dei commenti
cosa un po fa per paccate sbagliato
sbrighiamoci ok
penso che bossi abbia preso merlino
perché l'ho visto solo di rumori strani
sbrigare anche la camera è caduta vabbè
allora la soluzione
perché non si spezza non mi dire che ha
sostituito la soluzione con dell'acqua
normale non si sta attestando guardate o
forse sì forse sono solo io che ho un po
troppa ok guardate per fortuna è un po
tifoso non so è un po schifo di sito in
sito
se un sito questo schifo perché sembra
un cervelletto è bruttissimo ma o nostra
pure sgocciolando bene ma l'importante è
che siamo riusciti a completare uno club
a vincere la challenge non pensavo che
ce l'avremmo fatta
perché questa è stata molto più
difficile al buio e con la pila ma per
fortuna bosi non è super attento ai
rumori come granny messo di un bel
bibbia si sa prevedere una terza parte e
votate nel sondaggio chi volete che sia
il prossimo personaggio e ora vi lascio
qua 4 caselline su cui cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite e buona visione
ciao